si vous cherchez un tournoi de tennis en
plein mois de janvier pensez à la
verrière l'open fête d'ailleurs ses 10
ans cette année mais les structures du
club dernier roi sont limitées
l'association ne disposant que de deux
terrains couverts et 128 adhérents du
club ne peuvent donc pas jouer pendant
cette période l'organisation devient
vite un vrai casse tête
on limite le nombre de joueurs pour ce
tournoi on a 150 joueurs 45 femmes 105
hommes dans la semaine on établit six
matchs par soir il s'avère que les
joueurs de la région parisienne
finissent tard donc on ne peut commencer
dès match qu'après leur travail c'est à
dire 18 heures et on finisse fort tard
malheureusement fait n'est souvent à
minuit à la création du tournoi les
responsables du club cherchait un
créneau où il n'y avait pas d' open pour
ne pas subir la concurrence d'autres
compétitions le mois de janvier devient
vite une évidence limité en classement
et en nombre de joueurs l'accueil reste
une priorité qui séduit les compétiteurs
j'habite pas très loin ça doit faire la
troisième quatrième fois que je fais le
tournoi le club est assez sympa et
j'aime bien bien faire ce tournoi qui
est limitée dans les classements très
bien très très court trois très
conviviale très aimable non je ne sais
pas ça que j'aime bien les tournois qui
sont pas trop trop grand parce que
justement il ya un côté beaucoup plus
convivial qu'on n'a pas dans les grands
tournants donc j'apprécie cet or noir
avec les fortes chutes de neige six
rencontres ont été reportées
rendez vous tout de même le 3 février
prochain pour les phases finales